We briefly mentioned attitudes earlier in this lesson, but now we're going to
take a look at attitudes in a bit more detail. First, we can define attitudes
as an individual's favorable or unfavorable beliefs, feelings or actions toward
an object, an idea or a person. How do you feel about birth control, or
abortions? Or what about guns, or even the Detroit Red Wings? Well, we can look
at attitudes towards one of these examples by examining the three components of
our attitudes. Given my earlier discussion about the Red Wings, let's use that
as an example. Attitudes are comprised of three components. First, we have the
affective component. And this includes our feelings and emotions that are
associated with our belief. In my example, my affective component towards the
red wings would consist of enthusiasm, excitement, price and overall happiness.
Now, let's move on to talk about the second component and that is the
behavioural component